at one time i was homeless instead of
going home every night there was no home
to go to
life at home was very difficult i grew
up being abused
i lost my belt i lost respect i
embarrassed my family my vision was
pretty much non-existent i was able to
just about scrape by the medicals
i come out i have supreme confidence i'm
scared to death
i'm afraid of everything
i didn't care about living i just wanted
to die i got up and i felt the weight of
the world was lifted off my shoulders i
knew i was going to make a comeback
fighting this was designed for me and
what makes us who we are
i'm so far
my dream my vision for myself is to be
the greatest martial artist to ever live
i have always been a fighter there's
nothing i do better in this life than
fighting
there ain't never been a map like that
to me i was born to do this
nobody
[Music]
yeah check these out though right brand
new ones
for the holiday these are new sunglasses
they look like goggles yeah they're
swimming i like them they're kind of old
fashioned i used to have those when i
was younger they're very comfortable
yeah they look it they like beveled
around my eyes so they don't stick to my
face too much yeah they're quite
versatile looking yeah i feel like i'm
not even wearing them they don't know
that expensive though usually you're
quite flashy with your sunglasses that's
what i like about them they are quite
expensive i think they're about 100 quid
really yeah but they look cheap right
they do look cheap they look like
something i would have when i was like
six or seven years old it sort of sums
me up really is um
expensive but looks cheap okay yeah that
makes sense
um we were just talking about our
favorite uh little people
yeah what is the politically correct
term
uh i know i know one that's completely
off limits and it was something that i
was called a lot when i was growing up
[__] you can't say [__] anymore you
can say that because you i can say that
you've had it used against you yeah i
can say any anything that's been said
against me
i can click yeah exactly i've got i've
got the [__] pass
i've never had that no no never that
might chuck you uh favorite dwarf dwarf
for me it's always got to be wary davis
i've read his book twice i've met him a
couple of times mine would be the uh
have you ever seen me and myself and
irene uh no i haven't well people will
know straight away
seeing that there's a
uh jim carrey gets beaten up by a little
um you don't know his name
he's a dwarf so you don't know his name
but it was just you saying my favorite
dwarf is this person you don't know his
name
look it up in the credits yeah we're all
gonna break down the uh the youtube
boxing today me and g uh lawrence is a
little busy can we say what he's doing
um well people know that there's a baby
on the way so
let's just say he's a bit busy right now
uh
as we speak uh he's not delivering it
there's a professional there you know
i know lawrence doesn't know it all but
i'd hope he'd leave that to the medical
yeah exactly that's a hands-off kind of
thing uh just cheer on yeah yeah we're
gonna talk a little bit uh fighting the
day we obviously jay's in the house
and uh we're talking a bit of uh pro
boxing but a youtube boxing bit of mma
ufc chart we'll see where it goes sum up
the old fighting stuff people are always
asking for more fight content
let's give the people what they want in
the comments biggest news jj uh lost an
opponent in um alex wassabi
unfortunately he's concussed did you see
the training footage that was leaked
yeah i saw a bit of it wasabi look good
in that yeah he is he does look good i
was surprised when he thought deji i
mean me and you talked about it
beforehand i thought that deji after
doing the work after suffering those two
humiliating losses against jake paul
and then vinnie hacker which was really
bad yeah that was really bad with anyone
to get beat up by the guy who looks that
pretty is never bro they should have
just slaughtered him
um yeah so when he went to go fight
wasabi i thought right he's lost the
weight he's put the work in he's
dedicated for me i wanted to see him go
in there and just brutalize him because
i knew that deji has the ability to do
that because when he fought jake paul
everyone expected him to get knocked out
in the first round no one gave him a
shot all the success that deji had in
that first fight was a surprise to
everyone so i was there in manchester
arena obviously you were there
commentating and the biggest moment of
that night if people remember the
biggest cheer bigger than anything in
the main event was after the first round
when on the big screen they showed jake
paul's face as he was sat in his corner
full of blood with his nose busted
everyone was like oh my god deji is
doing it and the love that people had
for deji that night like that was even
though obviously ksi logan paul won was
the main event and it was such a great
fight that felt like the people's moment
there and deji even though he lost he
won the respect of everyone he peaked at
that moment yeah his his career has
never ever been that was his best
performance no
but his whole career peaked in that one
more yeah and i don't mean that in a
nasty way it's just the reality of it
was i think that he did better than he
thought he was going to do and everyone
else and therefore he got lazy and yeah
i think he has a he has that he has that
in him everyone's commenting on it who
knows him way better than i do so this
isn't me speaking this is the people who
know him best yeah
and obviously vinnie had uh
uh he didn't even try clearly turned up
over all the way out of shape and the
team he had around him as well i mean
you guys come out on true news they were
a joke
it was they were a joke it was like
it was really it was like lads abroad
but just like happened to be doing a
boxing match while they were there like
it was as if it was as if the holiday
had been booked and when should we just
yeah while we're at it we'll do a fight
there was a trip yeah and then when
deji's girlfriend got in oh and she was
like coming down the road oh my god that
she's wearing the my type the whole
thing that the more i think about it
then he took the knee in the middle of
the fight um i can't remember who said
it but recently someone said the game
plan was obviously in that fight we're
gonna take him out in the first round so
as soon as the first round finished
teddy's like right what do i do now and
his team are like we've got no plan we
didn't expect to get to that point yeah
look there's no way he thought jake paul
and didn't learn how to jog and get in
shape so he knew what he had to do he
just didn't do it yeah uh the wasabi one
he was
better in terms of his shape there's
this kid who's been training him called
daily who clearly knows knows enough to
get him in shape and to do the right
thing but mentally he bottled it in that
fight as soon as he felt the punches of
alex wassabi he didn't want to know do
you think that's what it was like the
fact that alex wassabi had like punch
power so so what ended up happening from
what i remember of that fight and i
didn't watch it that long ago um was at
first he was trying to open up but the
minute he did wasabi was countering him
so every time he threw first wasabi
being the bigger man and the quicker
longer ranger guy
he he fired back and deji ended up just
not throwing he he gave up in that fight
and that's something that as a trainer
this daily lad is going to have to drill
into him coming into the fight against
fousey which i think is weirdly now the
the main event
because of what's happened to ksi's main
event um but
yeah he gave up mentally in that fight
he was just trying to avoid getting hit
that was only that was all he was doing
yeah and i think daley now will know if
that is happening in round one you need
to scream at him and you need to slap
him around and be like bro this is gonna
your four losses in here if you if you
lose this four losses yeah which in a
pro boxing record is bad in youtube
boxing it's laughable like it's
everything you gotta beat someone and
it's on the biggest stage because people
you know i mean often you get fighters
that have four losses in a row but no
one's really heard of them or whoever oh
he's he's main event
every
every [__] time and he's very well
known and he's going in against fousey
who is like this is almost wwe levels of
character like deji and fousey are the
most odd characters online yeah they're
up there they really are wild they're
different and fousey's very polarizing
as well i mean even in his own
personality i mean
he probably divides himself
genuinely yeah there's two different
versions of fousey that we've seen in
the last few years right like there's
the overweight lunatic yeah then there's
this new guy who's focused who's
shredded who's all about his mental
health and
isn't
[__]
yeah but actually if you look at like
fuji's history i've followed him for
quite a few years he's actually gone
back and forth quite a few times there's
always times when he shreds down gets
into shape he's super determined and
then he'll go off the rails a little bit
i'm not saying that fuji's going to go
back off the rails but it's like no but
you can imagine yeah but the fusion
that's going to turn up on august 27th
against deji is the most dangerous
version of fousey which is fully
dedicated shredded you've seen some of
these pad work and things like that and
that kind of that version of fousey is
not the one that got batted around by uh
slim it's one that in my opinion is
gonna quite easily deal with deji and
now going back to what you said before
about deji fighting and giving up
against uh wasabi i think potentially
that could have happened but for me what
i saw against um wasabi was fear i saw
deji being scared i think those last few
fights it was gassing out because in his
last few facts he's gassed out and
that's one of the biggest reasons why he
lost if you remember how he fought
against jake and vinnie in those early
early rounds it was hell to lever he
didn't care he was using the fact that
he actually has a bit of size to him i
think we even described him going into
uh in that first round against vinnie
hacker as almost like a derek shazora
type he obviously didn't really have the
technical ability but he'll go in there
throw shots very similar to his brother
and if he catches you he's going to hurt
you and i think there's 50 50 i think
there was half scared of gassing and
half getting punched did not enjoy that
no uh so obviously he underestimated
wasabi as well the worry with fousey you
know we talked about his mental health
thing i'm just getting like that
reminder of what
tyson fury went through you know and
fousey and tyson fury are very similar
people in terms of not in terms of
boxing abilities but in terms of
enthusiasm
their mental challenges that they've had
throughout their life yeah they've both
said things that the rest of the world
listen to and go that's a load of [__]
you remember when he said drake was
going to turn up you did a whole event
like it's it's very similar to some of
the things tyson theory comes out and
what i'm saying is some people they can
become too focused to obsess for their
own good that there's burnout yeah and
that's the worry with with first after
this night i hope that he has a new goal
because people like him they always need
a goal but but back with the fight the
things i like about fousey is when he
fought slim and slim was clearly the
better boxer clearly had the cardio
fousey was out of shape
and jabbing fousey's head off was slim
but but fousey actually showed a lot of
determination he had a lot of heart so
he didn't show what deji showed in his
last fight like you know with the
weaknesses and the mental side of it
fousey was getting battered and he was
still going and a lot of people were
like making jokes but personally i had a
lot of respect for him because i thought
you know what you're in front of all
those people on a [__] show event no
glory in it and you are getting battered
and you are trying to kept walking
forward as well so that's the worry if
if you're coaching deji coming into this
is you've got a guy who's mentally
strong who's battle tested who can take
a beating and keep coming forward
something deji hasn't done yet
aside from the jake paul one but we that
was years ago now um and eventually gave
up in that fight as well so
whereas
fousey is mentally strong but he's gonna
be in shape to go round after round
after round there is i do not believe as
great as people are who are trying to
train deji that the dedication
can be on the same level from deji it
will be much more improved but i just
think like fousey is an obsessive maniac
he's completely focused he's calling
himself the wolf going into this fight
yeah he is he's crazy but i mean it
reminded me in a way when fousey was
just walking forward taking those shots
a bit like uh chris metinia when he
fought sean o'malley and he's very much
nobody know who christmas tina was
before that he was a step stepping
opponent and sean o'malley was just
teeing off on him for three he was a
[__] zombie this young kid right but
he gained so much respect after that and
it's very similar to fousey in a way
because now we know fuji's got a chin so
he has one confusing thing for me right
we most people are backing fousey to
beat deji because of what deji's done
lately and because let's not forget
fousey did get in there against alex
wasabi in a in a sparring match yeah and
beat the [__] out that was also wasabi
not having any boxing agreed agreed
training but at this level at this low
level of youtube boxing when we have
such minimal footage
of
people fighting i mean the main event
that's that swarms fella we'll get on to
that we we have no footage of him for
example right so that is at least we've
got something of foozy
i immediately thought you've got to put
fousey in the main event against jj i it
was it was such a natural it was like
look sorry deji you've done your
training but the main event is what
people are here for you've
they've already sold tickets you've
already let people down many times
before um you've got to step aside
you'll have your chance there's lots of
misfit boxing uh coming up on jazon
shout out to them they're going to do a
great job i'm excited to see what they
can do
but
fousey or or someone named who we've
seen fight before would have been a
great move in my opinion yeah just to
put them in the main event and go sell
the tickets exactly for so many reasons
obviously because the sole tickets have
sole pay-per-views everything like that
but jj needs to make a statement to jake
paul you know what i mean because jake
paul's just come off the off knocking
out tyron woodley he emphatically
knocked out tarantulas
jj needs to make a statement and fousey
would have been a good person to make a
statement against obviously as you said
you know we've seen him fight and i'm
not saying fousey is on the level of
tyron woodley
but
but there's respect there within this
community for fousey that is tough he's
taken many shots before kept coming he's
actually you can use the him beating
wasabi as here we're actually we're
getting somebody who's beaten with
somebody because jj's now saying like oh
swarms would easily beat people we've
seen foosie we've seen it happen yeah i
mean yes there's context and whatever
but
for for the people paying the money they
just need something believable so yeah
so so so
um in terms of the the deji fousey fight
before we do move on to the main event i
don't see a path of victory for deji
unfortunately right like a back dead
against no i thought jay paul was going
to win but i believed in deji's heart
and then going against vinnie hacker i
thought he was just going to wipe the
floor with him i just thought you know
guys even back then against wasabi i
think dude
as i said before i thought he'd lost the
weight he's obviously been training he
looked good he did a little bit like
what some ufc fighters do when they lose
a fight they'll go away not do any media
they'll come back and they'll be a
monster they'll be a different version
of themselves in a way it's very similar
to ronda rousey it's funny but
so one thing i want to give credit to
the dead tree forwards the natural
talent he does have in terms of
in terms of all these youtube boxing
lads
the when he's
got energy and i watch him hit pads and
i i see things wrong i'm like that's all
right there's some talent there i'm not
i'm not sitting here going he has no
talent that's not what i'm saying it's
it's whether or not he's dedicated
enough but when i watch him hit pads
there's technique there there's ability
there's natural power
i just
feel like the mental edge with fousey is
so much stronger he's just so much more
convincing so the one path that i do see
for deji is obviously when fousey fought
slim he was much bigger he wasn't as
lean as he is right now you must admit
you must have lost about
30 pounds exactly
do you think that might have affected
his chin that chin when he was able to
just walk forward because obviously he
was much heavier walk forward against
slim and take those shots and does does
deji hit harder than slim do you know i
i think deji will hit harder than slim
but what i think is the conditioning of
fousey will mean
that it would take so much from deji to
get rid of fousey because because the
fitter you are the harder it is to
finish the
someone so and that's just general
boxing um and we're talking about fousey
who i've been watching his social media
like last few months he's been like yeah
i'm just going to go and bail out 10
miles like it's nothing yeah bro he's so
switched on yeah he's like on a
different and that was like two months
ago he was just doing like 10ks like
they were nothing bro so he can't outbox
him deji can't go in there with the idea
that he's gonna outbox fousey he has to
go in there with the same mentality as
he had against um vinnie in the first
round helpful ever i'm gonna pressure
he needs to just go in there not trying
to box him but just try and really
really rough him up and catch him with a
big shot and make fousey pay for all
those pounds you know what first he
needs to do fast pace yeah i i i'm
coming out the gate and i'm going to
make deji's cardio i'm going to test
that to the limit in that first round if
i'm fuzzy i'm going i can push the pace
on you more than you can do to me yeah
so the quicker i go the harder you're
gonna the quicker you're gonna drowned
exactly exactly um
moving on to the main event right
through no fault of ksi's and i
definitely i feel like he's been given a
bit of a rough ride this week uh alex
wassabi has pulled out confusion is that
the official reason
you can see the kids been sparring hard
like we've seen the clip of that so i
genuinely don't think that he's pulled
out of fear he he hasn't given that off
at all
um so i i hope we see it actually i hope
i hope that we do get this fight uh
because i think jj could do with a few
quick back-to-back fights just to get
the ring rust off and that's what this
is all about but and it makes sense the
story lands there obviously he beat jj
so jake paul's bj sorry beat deji yeah
so the story line makes the storyline's
still there but i think collectively the
whole internet when the opponent was
announced
were surprised what was your thought i
thought it was a joke you sent the
graphic into the chat and i was like oh
this is a fan made poster obviously
because the guy it looked like he just
been edited in really quickly i had no
idea who he was i know i've seen the
meme where they go they're bursting
through the daughter dick yeah waking up
swarms and he finds out he's fighting jj
i saw another beam someone posted where
it looked like when he said oh swarm
just delivered my delivery
so have you had you heard of this kid
before i promise
i never heard of swarms in my life so
i'm not the best person to ask because i
i remember the track that they did
together when jj released that track but
i didn't know who that guy was because
i'm not a [__] grime artist [__]
fan yeah i don't really know what the
[__] i'm looking out
but um my first thought was could they
have got someone who was known in the
industry who we've seen fight before so
austin mcbroom
at that point didn't have a fight could
they have made an offer cancelled
i knew jake wasn't going to happen
because they want to build up the jig
and that's a smart move and that's that
of course it would be very dumb for them
to take that off the off the cuff just
to try and prove a point but maybe a
mcbroom maybe uh
taylor hold uh maybe bryce hall
you know those type of characters um and
then obviously you've got feyer's temper
who was without an opponent who had a
very good showing against kenny
uh
i mean salt puppy oh yeah yeah you know
some puppy actually looks like a really
decent boxer
chubby guy yeah he moves he's already on
the card you could have taken anyone
from the card and pulled him off or
fousey pushing him up idubbbz idubbbz as
well there's
idubbbz dr mike idubbbz was so
underrated by the way i actually
messaged him and i was like you know
what you have talent yeah like he was in
there with a really difficult guy he
showed heart power i want to see more
items in misfit boxing when they do that
so the point of all this conversation
we're having right now is youtube boxing
has grown to the point where there is so
many names that you can pick from
because everyone's desperate to get in
the ring to main event and ksi is the
number one guy obviously jake paul's on
his own path doing his own thing but
in the youtube boxing world yes because
of the way logan went with mayweather
jake's now fighting profile that is the
lottery ticket that is the golden ticket
to be able to fight jj on a main main
event and at last minute you can call
your price probably exactly yeah put it
in i think the idubbbz would have said
yes exactly he's a gay [__] you
think right who wants it and you have so
many people being like me me me me
swarms
suppose was the best i could get this is
the thing right so this he has the
problem he might be a hard man he might
be tough as [__] but we have no idea
though that's the only issue as
so to sell this fight i i i'm thinking
i'm commentating this i want to know
more i went on youtube
and i just searched swarms
boxing you know
there's nothing bro we're born dry but
that's the thing youtube boxing when it
started when back in the day when it was
joe weller versus theo and joella ksi it
was all about who would win if this big
youtuber fought this big youtuber and
that was the appeal and then they did
the big event ksi logan paul jake paul
deji boxing ability never really came
into it because it wasn't about boxing
ability you know what i mean if anything
the more scrappy it looks the better now
since i gave became my fan favorite yeah
exactly like obviously when swarms was
announced people were disappointed
mainly because nobody knew who he was
and it also takes away from that
original um idea of the biggest names
fighting each other because swarms is
not a big name at all like no one's ever
heard of him but then obviously the
justification from jj side and obviously
jj's team side was well he's a better
opponent and he's more technically
advanced and things like that nobody
cares about these things right people
want to see jj fight a big name that
we've all heard of there's a story line
there great but ultimately no one has
heard us off swarm so it's like
nobody cares uh-huh that he could be did
you watch the
manager of jj explaining it mum's
yeah yeah very interesting video because
he was there in a vest sat on a throne
now if i was there's nothing wrong with
the rest come on listen i've been
actually doing a bit of research on this
man's do you know he is quite famous and
he's been famous for a long time
so he was in a music video he's a
musician he was on tmz back in the day
he knocked someone out in the street and
and he had a music video featuring mila
kunis and a few other
females anyways yeah so this man's
tailor has been around the scene for a
long time which is how he manages jj
obviously yeah but i was quite
interested when i saw that video because
if i wanted to make a serious video
clearing things up the last thing i
would do is put on a vest and sit on a
throne
mum's i'm sorry
no i think he's a great obviously he
knows what he's doing yeah but it's not
a bit odd i think the internet already
came uh with a few of those memes about
how um
the sale of the fight was based on him
being late to to see jj and stuff like
that it's it's oh no that was that was a
word so he was trying to build the
storyline yeah i don't think he'd
consult with jj beforehand because they
may have had a bit of a thing in their
group chat or whatever where they've
gone listen no one's happy we need to
try and sell this fight all right we
need to build a story line we had the
wasabi beat deji in the previous one
what can we say and then moms comes out
and goes
so
one time they were meant to have a
scheduled appointment and he was three
hours late and this made jj livid he
wanted to take his head off
yeah
in combining that with the lack of a
anyone in the influencer arena knowing
who this guy is and then it's having
zero boxing knowledge of this guy yeah
it's a hard sell i don't know what we're
getting like this is the thing right is
in boxing you have to be careful yeah
right you have to have people who know
how to box in there when you haven't got
the head gods and all of the rest of it
of course and they will you know they
they're fighting pro rules by my
understanding
like jj it looks sharp jj it looks in
the best shape of his life i have never
seen him look anywhere near what he
looks already and i've got no doubt
we're seeing a new and improved version
that's that that's clear as day
jade could [__] kill this kid right
are you always funny about this yeah
this is a dissolved view
one thing i'll give swarms is he made a
video i saw that and it was quite funny
and i thought okay so there's there's a
bit of character and banter there he's
no youtuber though is he uh it's you
could see it was a it was a rapper
trying to do his best version of a
youtuber and and i this guy who can
blame him he's probably been made enough
uh he's like [__] it i ain't got a butt
oh no it's great looking at his flat he
could do with extra cash no no i'm
joking
i'm joking
this guy might knock me out for this
but in my head i was just like
okay i get why you've said yes yeah
right this is a good opportunity
the whole country now knows who you are
if he goes in there and looks okay
it elevates this guy beyond belief he
can't lose well he's in the words of
jesus
they're gonna do a documentary on him
swarms can't lose he could go in there
get knocked out in the first round
where's the conor mcgregor he could say
i got to quadruple my net worth for half
a [__] foot sewing me up
you know what right
you've just made a damn good point in a
way like that was the one thing that it
did remind me of is like the story of
like rocky for example like the
well-known fighter who handpicks an
unknown guy yeah to fight on the main
event in front of the whole city you
know they'll make films about this one
day
swarms has a chance to be rocky balboa
yeah and that is my best sale i've got
you know what i mean that's all i've got
and that's not my fault it's and it's
not jj's fault yeah it's the situation
that people are in
um
but you're just like if i'm disowned i'm
getting a guy over there into the boxing
gym
to get some footage of him and get it
out now exactly
if we don't see any boxing footage
it's because they've got boxing footage
and it's awful and that's what worries
me a little bit i hope he's in a
position to defend himself because we
want to see jj tested to some degree
because this is all about him proving
himself as a boxer if he goes in there
drops the guy in 10 seconds okay well
done it's a great shot but we need some
element of
of competitiveness to prove that this is
worthy exactly and here's what he needs
to do
think about the wasabi storyline think
about the jake storyline what do they
both have in common
both of them beat up deji so swarms
needs to in the next two weeks the
swarms if you're watching this find deji
wherever he is go and jump make sure
he's big dog's not get it on camera make
sure he makes there get it on camera
shoot it well i know he's not a youtuber
for say but like you need to film this
he needs to go beat up deji and then the
storyline is set and then we'll care
about it you know i think that can be
part of this
and if you can't find deji then
randolph i think someone close to jj
randolph
one of the one of the one of the
assignments
yeah which side men would trigger him
the most which one does he love the most
i feel like simon he's close oh no
definitely simon those guys have been
friends for years yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah so find simon
yeah the one good thing that they've got
going for them is is is jj could fight a
broom and people will turn up nick
uh
literally
that is a i really um that's the one
thing we've got to look at is this is
the fight before the fight really this
was never
in jj's eyes this was all about just
getting back in the ring getting the
engine going again and then we're going
to get a mcbroom then we're going to get
real tests yeah of course but that's all
well and good for him like i know that
he tweeted out saying yeah this is just
a fact to get the ring rust off but it's
like this could have been a sparring
session like i don't understand how you
need to get the ring raw stuff on the
zone pay-per-view in front of a sold out
oh tour i think the fact that it's
pay-per-view
with wasabi nobody was complaining but
i've seen more people moaning now
obviously because there was a story line
with wasabi people know about wasabi
he's got 10 million subscribers on
youtube he he
yeah he adds to the value to a degree
not a massive degree because wasabi's
career
was revived in a big way by jj but
because he had a win over deji he was
something he's had time to sink in i was
like initially quite upset about the
whole swarms thing um obviously because
you know no one really cares about it
but i do agree like fousey deji is the
real main event now and it should be the
main event like people are far more
excited for that fight than they are for
this ksi swarms because if swarms wins
what does that do for youtube
about all of this i i do logan paul
versus swan i do feel for tedchi because
if there's one thing that this was all
about was taking the pressure off deji
like you've been in so many big fights
where it was like now you've got to win
it was like okay now he's the underdog
he's not the main event it should be
fine and it's like all of a sudden it's
like dude
that's just the millionaire soundtracks
just playing um i know well swarms
eventually we'll go and fight mayweather
and that will be youtube boxing and
that's how it will go
good old flight
uh the thing is that we want to look
back in years to comment this whole
youtube boxing era and be like and then
there was ksi joe weller ksi logan paul
casey logan paul 2 logan paul goes and
fights mayweather and then jake goes and
knocks out ufc champions and then jj
fought swarms and then you know what i
mean like it just feels like there's a
step back there's been a little bit of
jj and joel weller again getting a
little bit i wouldn't mind that as a
sequel obviously joelle has not been
training so yeah it makes sense but i
think i wouldn't mind seeing that fight
run back now for the nostalgia value i
think that
i'd love to see joe buckland in the ring
one day for his own
completion of the journey like from
going in the ring then sort of out of
the ring commentary sort of thing and
then
you know what you know what's funny one
of the best youtube call-outs of all
time never actually came to fruition and
that was when when a nissan gabe just
beat swingler and he's like joella what
did he say
that would have been such an amazing
fight that would have been such an
amazing fight before gibber went to
fight uh jake i rated joe so much though
afterwards just going look it was a fun
moment but you kicked my eye
but but joe is a tough kid and i'd love
to see him i would love to see him win a
fight you know what i mean that moment
because obviously we know he's a big wwe
fan and he's such him and jay or
something like that i love him such a
[__] james swingler jay swingler
jay's looking big now yeah
yeah they're both in shape they're both
about the same size that would be a
dream fight wow for me i don't think
i've ever seen anyone sort of suggest
that so yeah jace winger they're both
great characters they're both fun
they're both like athletic yeah i i'll
be great i'd [__] love that i mean if
misfit is going to carry on
they need a main event for the next one
yeah and that is a main event oh that's
a main event in it yeah you're welcome
and you remember johnny johnny nelson he
said he was going to train joel johnny
nelson yeah daddy's here the other day
soon he could beat you sick in his prime
i was like johnny
um we're going to get on to you aj later
on but there's a few other fights
happening that night we have kenny
versus face sensei very interesting yeah
an interesting one because people are
picking kenny to beat
sensei which feels a bit wild in a way
well it it it is because sensei has all
of the experience and kenny's new to it
but kenny's got a lot of natural talent
i will say that yeah you look decent
against there was a temper that you
fought last year obviously he lost that
fight he managed to get well they gave
him the decision at the end he was
overturned afterwards
he's got decent natural ability but in
my opinion sensei's just a level above
you know i mean it's in his
blood a fighter well he's a martial
artist but he's for professionals
professionals but when you say he's a
fighter what i've seen some of the
criticism from uh
vidal and um leon
is about him mentally being like a bit
of a nice guy and like is he
does he have the eye the tiger does he
have it in him to go in and hurt because
what people are looking at is the
sparring sessions that have came out of
faze versus gabe and faiz versus uh jj
he lost those in sparring yeah you're
right but it's sparring and i do think
that you know sensei he wasn't coming in
100 in shape he was coming in to help
the other guy he wasn't trying to hurt
the other guy just before their big
fight
i think he he had a little
little something that he was holding
back maybe i don't think he was given
his hundred hundred percent you know i
remember he looked really good against
um overflow i don't know if that's his
name trimbo when he came with the liver
shot it was the the only proper finish
on that card and near the eye of the
tiger then if we're talking about eye of
the tiger the problem is what's the yeah
it's like overt flow wasn't a real
testing sense that he's a martial artist
but he's not a striker of course um it's
that bad ashgren thing yeah i think i
think sensei on a full training camp is
going to look very different i think
you're right he's holding something back
and the guy's name is sensei bro i think
he's going to give do you know what he's
been uh i i watched him in their way
chat about it and he said podcast by the
way yeah shout out to the boys on the
breakdown uh
he
he said um i'm gonna go in there and i
wanna [__] have fireworks i wanna go
after it i wanna punch up i don't wanna
striking boxing thing i want to go in
there and get into it straight up and
that was for me like okay yeah you've
had just about enough of people talking
about because jj picked uh him to lose
it and i think that's a it's a good
motivating factor oh he wants to prove
yeah like yeah i'm the i'm the [__]
martial artist because i don't know if
you know from from memory i believe he
was one of the people who helped train
temper oh yeah and temper is now viewed
as one of the best yeah one of the best
guys i mean
i i i thought the templar against kenny
he was really good he should
underestimate him before composure a use
of the job a use of the reach he's
quicker he looked great and and uh
him versus slim is a fantastic fight
yeah definitely slim's almost gone under
the radar because he's not been on these
big big cards but i know that he's been
doing a lot of the adam seller cards
over in like abu dhabi and things like
that i like him as a character i mean
he's got a win over fousey he's a great
character yeah i had no idea who he was
before the fousey fight but i remember
fousey was trying to sort of play like
the stern lot before that whereas slim
was in his face screaming she normally
reminds me of in a style like a diaz
okay like like kind of yeah skinny guy
but can punch all day you know what's
funny i was thinking max holloway he
kind of looks a little bit yeah a little
bit like max like same build thing you
know it's like skinny looking but can
keep punching and punching and punching
and has that technique and he'll taunt
you in there exactly and the interesting
thing about this fight of um temp uh
versus um
it's like slim is gabe said he'll fight
the winner and that was meant to happen
a while ago yeah him versus slim and
obviously with misfits again that's
another great fight that we can see down
the road so
i'm uh i'm excited for them yeah slim's
got knockout power as well he's knocking
people out on those other cars i don't
really know the level of his previous
opponents but it's a it's a big test the
only thing with those cards there was a
little bit of um
yeah debate on the validity of them
because
salah had some very questionable uh wins
where it looked like the other guy had
gone down a little easy and then after
the fact he'd come out and went oh yeah
they paid me to take a dive oh
there was that white lad who um yeah i
remember a stocky kid uh
came in and uh yeah it was a bizarre but
look i believe in there slim's ability
looked very decent that is going to be a
decent yeah yeah a very good fight who
else is on the court though salt papi's
on the card as well coming off a very
good winning
favorite soul puppy a weird uh well
because the way that you dealt with
hamlet i love hammy's a good friend of
mine but wow
i thought he looked like the best boxer
that night he did in terms of like raw
talent you're looking at him like you've
been you've been training with the lean
counters and things yeah yeah and the
way he was like
he was taunting it it had the confidence
of someone who's been in the ring for
many years to some degree he's
definitely trained boxing yeah he knows
what he's doing
yeah yeah it reminded me of like a pro
versus a novice yeah like it did look
like that yeah and ham as well he isn't
a pushover like he obviously he's had a
couple fights before he used to box when
he was younger he'd lost a lot of weight
for that fight i know although he was
doing it for a good cause he was
fighting with canter he was fighting
with he put a funny tweet out the other
day so for those of you who don't know
ham he fought salt papi on the last card
he loses that fight but the whole time
he had cancer
um he's he's fine now he's cured but
then he got a tweet out the other day
saying all these youtubers pull it out
i thought we can say i mean he's got a
point doesn't he i mean fair play for
that reason we've got to give him a
shout out [__] oh good on you mate
pappy did make easy work of him and
looked really good and i'm really
excited to see him get back in the ring
because if he wins this fight he could
main like come in another misfits event
this is the weird thing is what we've
seen with gabe and gabe already had a
name don't get me wrong but gabe has
used fighting to propel his name into
another level
and we're going to see other youtubers
do that but we're also going to see the
flip side where other youtubers go from
having a level of clout and credit to
getting [__] up and being embarrassed
you know what i mean we could see that
you know what's funny when whenever
there's like a big youtube event whether
it's like ksi logan paul or like ksi
joella there's always like i'm gonna i'm
gonna ruin your career i'm gonna end
your career no you're gonna lose all
your subscribers no one's gonna care
about you you're a meme i don't think
there's really been a youtuber that's
lost a fight and then suffered
their like their career suffered as a
result of that i would unless they
stopped making videos completely like
obviously deji
since he's been boxing he's not really
made many videos so his channel has
naturally gone down but like logan for
instance obviously it's logan paul but
he lost to jj and his channel has only
gone from strength to strength i think
some people have
wanted to see more from joella since his
first fight oh yeah i think in terms of
the breaks he took of his own decision
um but yeah i agree i think at this
level
you shouldn't be scared of losing no not
for your reputation because you've got
more bravery and balls getting in there
there's way more upside yeah that's why
i'm thinking like when there was the
position open
yeah exactly deji's had humiliating
defeats and it it hasn't hurt them in
any way really exactly but it's all this
is the new way on youtube with boxing at
the moment to sort of make a name for
yourself and that's why it's still going
back to the swarms thing it confuses me
when that position came open it's like
right we need someone to fight ksi is
the main event who can we
yeah i'm not disappointed in swarms as a
guy taking it why wouldn't he i'm
disappointed that other people did not
want that yeah other people who
who want to be in that position outside
of jake paul i don't think that there
was any
real desire showing to get on that
[__]
you'd think someone like a drummer
vitali who fought in the last swing
against that christian hamby even
someone like him yeah so that's the
thing like nowadays if you really want
to make a name for yourself on youtube
get in the boxing ring like a salt papi
now if he wins this fight you can
imagine his subscribers on tick tock or
youtube will go up tremendously i mean
like like many people had never heard of
the guy neither of them no i'm like this
guy's wild exactly
he's a personality you can get in there
sure
exactly and it doesn't matter about
boxing skill as well you just go in
there and just make a name for yourself
and that's that's the best thing about
this whole youtube boxing fiasco oh
they've they've done a new poster for
him thank god has he got your shirt off
in this one kind of
i must admit i'm not i've seen him
sitting down on his couch
he didn't look ready no he's definitely
not ready he doesn't look like he's in
shape like jj looks like he's ready for
love island
and this fella looks like he's ready
here it's gonna be in the arena that
night and when people are watching at
home it's gonna be the big build up to
the deji fousey that'll be the peak and
then after that it will sort of just go
down like i don't think people are gonna
be that excited to see jj versus uh
swarms and also as well when jj beats
swarms no matter how he does it he has
to be sort of like careful with what he
says on the mic because you can't call
out like jake paul after beating swarms
in like a lackluster way you know what i
mean he can't be like look what i did to
swarms and it's like yeah but the guy's
[__] nobody
that's the issue unfortunately unless we
say swarms show early on some real
ability as the rounds go on as well it
gets worse and worse looking for
uh for jj well i think that's one thing
we've kind of got to give jj credit for
is it's a lose-lose like there isn't
really he's admitted that himself yeah
he said i'd rather take a small l now to
get a big w later on and i think that
that's
admirable because basically it's more
risk than reward yeah the the the what
is there there's there's there's very
little reward here yeah for jj so i
think the fact that the show is carrying
on for the fans is fair you know i mean
i've got to give him credit for that but
i just hope that this guy is prepared
and as you said before it's the element
of the unknown we don't know what's
what's going to happen because we have
no idea about this guy it's actually a
little bit like the joella jj fight if
you remember before that we had no idea
what joe weller was going to look like
because we hadn't seen anything in it of
him apart from him yeah so in that way
it's kind of exciting because it's
interesting like if swarms looks good
then ultimately we're like oh wow
oh then
i just i want to see and i mean this
from a purely non-sexual way i want to
see him with a shirt off
sorry
[Laughter]
i'm good from the uh where stop if you
do swarms of winds in fact like he
knocks out jj in a round god he could
say whatever the [__] he wants
he gets on the mat calls out jake paul
jake paul swarms jake paul logan paul
any of the balls yeah
i'm just saying they're like what the
[__] just happened it goes full circle
swarms knocks out jj calls out theo
baker i won that original oh bro that
would be so good deals just in the crowd
like [__] you i'm not good theo baker
kenny baker any of the bakers
going back to dwarfs
there is the jake paul situation well i
mean obviously and jj admitted this
himself jake paul was uh he took a dub
from this whole situation because jj had
a lot to say about you know uh jake
fighting haseem rahman and and you know
that fight falling through he was like
understanding why that fight didn't
happen it was something to do with the
weight so apparently um ratman jr was
meant to make was it 205 and that was
the agreement so he was sending um the
weight to the commission saying look i'm
gradually making this weight and then
they actually officially weighed him in
and he was way over the limit chill
sonnen actually suggested that
the kid was just going to come
way in
our way and be like do you think he was
going to do a bit of like an mma caught
well he's just going to do it all
overnight
no i think i think what chill was
suggesting is he's going to come in
overweight and he's going to be there
the night before being like you either
pay me the full rate i ain't going out
there and he's trying to put him into a
corner but then jake was like you can't
tell us what to do yeah so in advance
jkc and they're coming and was like well
[__] this [__] off now there's no point
he's not taking it seriously
and i get that it's a shame though
because he released the footage of the
sparring and i was like there's a
competitive fight that's exciting and i
like that we've seen that yeah because a
win over him i mean it's exactly what
jake paul needs like everyone's saying
he needs to fight a boxer this is a
boxer this would have been the next step
in the journey but it also takes jake
paul away from ksi who's currently
fighting influencers so in a weird way
it kind of helps he's already on the
other level now though isn't he i think
because he's only beaten mma guys
who are significantly smaller than i
agree then jj there's still that element
of question there's still a level above
oh yeah in terms of what he's achieved
100 but but but what i'm saying is if jj
goes in there and looks unbelievable
even against a guy who we have no idea
what the hell is turning up the
questions are there the excitement is
there and that we're like okay jj
knocked someone out because jj hasn't
really done the knockout yet like in
terms of his his actual fighting you
know i mean like we've seen it in
training but have we seen jj knocked
someone out in training yeah i don't
know that was a long time ago yeah
wasn't that in the joel account yeah it
was yeah okay so that was yeah exactly
so so so that's what i'm talking about
is we need a knockout we need a flash
knockout we need something spectacular
yeah and that'll get the tongues wagon
and everyone interested so jake paul
calls out jj when the fight first goes
um when the fight first gets cancelled
between wasabi jake's like listen i'll
come to london you be the a side
whatever you want i will tell you
whatever you're playing alex i'll take
that exactly and then obviously jj was
like no and i don't blame him like
people were saying oh jj's ducking him
jj scared
bro i wouldn't take that far either not
being scared or anything but it's a case
of
jake's a different level right now this
obviously you said before business wise
it doesn't make sense for many different
reasons it doesn't make sense
if they do this right they could make a
[__] phone as well
it was jake paul
just trying uh
in a clever it was a clever move in his
sense because he's thinking this guy is
just coming back
i'm razor sharp right now yeah we're not
in a similar position i'm going to have
a massive advantage and i get why jake
would have won
probably yeah yeah most likely would
have won but jake knew that this is the
perfect opportunity i'm already a level
above but
it doesn't make sense it's it's
not what i want i want to see both guys
at their best much like what you want
from the the highest level in boxing we
we don't want tyson fury fighting
anthony joshua after a long layoff we
want him now to fight anthony joshua or
or you sick so yeah i i get it uh i
think jj handled it perfectly actually
obviously they went back and forth on
twitter and jj said listen when i take
all that's the thing so then jj for
those who don't know said jake paul
let's [__] do this next year i'm
gonna send you a contract wembley
stadium uh winner takes all
i really hope they don't do winner takes
all and then jake comes back and says
you've got to admit i'm the better boxer
then we'll make it happen jj was like
[__] it you're the better boxer let's do
it and i like that it's ballsy from both
of them it's like we're finally going to
put the the end of this i don't think
they should do winner take all i think
why not jake jake loves a bet than he in
a way it will be the most amazing thing
you know it's funny though yeah but but
it they both are bringing so much to the
table that they both deserve to this is
the type of fight that is like
life-changing even even for these guys
it will be like probably whatever
they're worth it'll probably earn them
half of that again this is the
mayweather mcgregor of youtube 100
percent of the be all and end all that
you don't get bigger than this
there's a rematch always a rematch close
in there as well no i'm just oh of
course yeah whoever wins as a rematch
there was a rematch
if he would oh really yeah yeah so
there'll be a rematch between these two
no matter what happens even if it's a
draw because we start with ksi logan
paul um but yeah winner takes all
there's going to be a few people that
that have there
yeah i'm pretty sure ksi's manager and
jake's manager yeah liam don't be
[__] stupid exactly leaves we're all
getting a piece of this part exactly
thank you very much
yeah that's the problem with why top
level boxing is the the mess that it's
in actually is all the people at the
table eating off the plate which is one
thing i've actually enjoyed about how
quickly youtube boxing seems to get made
by comparison it does obviously we had
so many facts scheduled this summer it
was meant to be the summer of youtube
fights and all of them have either been
cancelled or postponed or changed
to fight austin next month is that
actually confirmed next month so the
same thing everything staples uh
everything okay cool because he's being
cleared i know that he had some sort of
brain injury or something well it wasn't
an injury respected he went to a doctor
who wasn't the normal doctor and that
doctor i i think was being overly
cautious
uh whereas the normal doctor i was like
yeah you're fine it's not it wasn't a
big deal it's quite interesting
apparently you think these articles
would have been done like foreign so
according to uh i watched the uh the
william wills podcast and uh vidal and
leon said uh something about gabe going
to an easy to get who doctor instead of
the one he should have went to ah
that just made us laugh we were having a
laugh
i don't know if we could put this in but
we were having a laugh about goob the
idea of him going to the the doctors to
get his brain checked oh my god and he's
like lad
i'm mental yeah got me cleared
how
yeah i [__] love giving me i would i
can't wait to see him back in the ring
because he looks so good like he put a
photo on ed before a week before he was
so shrouded bro he's looking great and
he's so uh i can't wait to see him fight
again and obviously he looks so good
against holder he's i know someone else
that's benefited massively from youtube
boxing so you know what i i think uh the
potential for gabe
although he doesn't have a natural enemy
in the way jake and jj do he's loved by
the people isn't it i think that there's
there's a there's something there with
him where he could squeeze his way into
a big fight yeah again yeah of course
well he was i know he's made an event
that's why i suggested to logan i was
like you know gabe's actually a good
fight for you a very challenging fight
logan and jake and all those will always
look over good because of how easily
jake was meant to do that
i get that and uh but i just think uh in
time i think it'll show his quality
exactly no he already has against holder
but here's the thing
gabe is is best when he is um the
underdog and when he is underestimated
like against taylor holder if you
remember everyone was saying he has no
chance against taylor holder because
taylor was bigger and people were still
blinded by that jay paul loss people
don't realize how good gibb is and
gabriel's gonna prove again when whoever
he fights next i think he batters big
broom i don't think it's even a
competition really i think he absolutely
annihilates him because mcbroom in my
opinion well obviously he beat bryce
hall but bryce hall with absolute dog
[__]
no i'm being honest no it's so true yeah
he looks so bad but big bro technically
he was okay bryce hold it bryce is uh i
actually like bryce as a character in
this oh yeah yeah he's he's very um
necessary and i want to see him
necessarily yeah i want to see him in
the in the in the ring again because
he's he's got heart and he's got the
character it's the hands he hasn't got
the hands his hands are trapped yeah but
he's awful like there's no one that you
beat you need to put him in all right
against someone that's also [__] he no
he needs he this is the way i think him
and him and taylor holder have this
weird beef now oh really oh they hate
each other now yeah you keep up with
this stuff no i just invade my social
media okay you know what i'd love to see
bryce hall against
ed matthews do you know who ed matthews
is so ed matthews just knocked out
simple simon the 51 year old 19 year old
because
you talk about that for a little bit
because you don't know too much about
all this i did mention it on a podcast
recently but you guys were saying no i
was listening to it you're saying like i
don't think you were getting you
i i thought the girl was the daughter of
no no she's not yeah so now did you see
the the way that matthew's knocked out
the simple salmon though well i mean he
battered the old man i know i don't
think he's very good as a boxer
obviously i think he was he was pretty
[__] but so is bryce hall and he calls
out bryce hall and gabe when he won
bryce hall versus ed matthews would be a
really good fight and ed matthews has
got the personality as well like he is
massive on tick tock he's got a whole
like army behind him as well like cult
court following seems a bit mad like do
you do hs ticky tocky mate what do you
think i've never [__] heard of this i
think we should park it there okay on
the old influencer box we could go all
day
we've also i've i've gone into a
position where i've got no idea what the
[__] i'm talking about uh
but
i'm looking forward to it i'm gonna be
commentating i know i'm so excited for
that as well obviously
as well yeah deaf always yeah um but
yeah you you're one of the original
people in youtube boxing i mean you
commentated the first ever theo versus
joe weller you were there for ksi versus
joe weller ksi logan paul like you are a
pioneer of the space in a way so it's
good that you are now right there again
i'm excited i'm excited and i the
difference is my boxing knowledge now
compared to where it was is so much
different so hopefully with a good
microphone some good boxing knowledge
i'll do better and that's the thing that
production as well i mean you've got the
zone production it's going to be top
tier who else is commentating do you
know keemstar
and uh one of the disowned guys will be
there as well okay cool so now we've got
the main panel yeah but we've got other
guys like wade are gonna be involved um
there's like big zoo and all that okay
cool it's gonna be a good night it's
gonna be so good i think logan's gonna
be in the building so maybe he might
make a pit stop okay on commentary will
uh jake paul be there do we know that
because you remember when jake beat gabe
and then it cut to the shot of uh jj
who was sat in the crowd looking
disappointed like we need that moment we
need that jj looks at jake paul yeah i
want you to spawn or swarms if swarm if
these jj points out jake paul they do a
bit of the face off god they can't no
there's no way swamps is winning is it
like really he can't
we'll clip that together for when
someone's knocked out jj in one round
yeah
we'll do a bit of uh pro boxing as well
and pro fighting we've got a big fight
coming up anthony joshua versus
alexander yousek i've just seen some
footage of aj hitting the pads
and he looks
dangerous how is he looking right now in
terms of size because if you remember
when he fought andy ruiz the first time
he was carrying a lot more muscle a lot
more size and then when he lost to ruiz
he came back and he was a lot leaner and
he obviously was going to choose to go
for that style very much sort of like at
the end of the gel approach keeping his
distance things like that we know now
based on the last fight with yousick
that aj isn't going to go in there and
try out box use it because it didn't
work for him
he's going to have to try and knock him
out
and hurt him
he looks a little bigger i'd say a
little bigger but that's good that
benefits what he needs to do i think
music looks bigger
than what he was okay yusik looks
much bigger than what he was as well he
looks like
jacked okay so that might work against
him in terms of the speed
attributes they're trying to do a bit of
like uh i think usic is anticipating a
shorter fight so you succeed i ain't
gonna let you come in and just outpower
me okay i'm gonna carry some extra power
myself so i've got something for you
because the game plan's quite obvious
from aj isn't it like go in there and
knock him out well it it's to go in
there and to not try and and punch with
them in terms of
accuracy so like if you look at the
first fight aj is trying to land perfect
shots on the chain of yousick yeah a new
six heads like a [__] all over the
shop you know he goes yeah he's moving
his feet constantly he's moving his head
constantly so when when aj is trying to
land that perfect shot he has no
hope of really connecting to the way
we've seen him do it with other people
yeah when you've got you know plodders
in in in the heavyweight division who
are nothing like yousick so
um i think he's going to go in there and
try and hit him to the body there's a
lot of body shots in the training i've
watched okay and the one thing that did
get a reaction or the the the one or two
things that was in there was the body
shot of to yousick they did back him up
a little bit there was an end of a round
where you could see using walking off a
bit like because jj aj hits hard very
hard very very hard like one of the
hardest punches in boxing actually and
he also knows how to gradually break you
down he's he's not common for aj to get
that one punch knockout but with like
the likes of like dillian white and
pulev and povetkin like he he knows how
to wear you down yeah he grinds you out
and but the the the problem that aj has
got is what he usually does is he picks
around early on third or fourth and
he'll go in and try and tear you up a
bit yeah and then he'll go okay i took a
bit out off
get my gas tank back three rounds later
going again like you did with uh was
povetkin um
pool ever all that as well
um he did that with pure lev especially
there was that heavy onslaught then he
took the four rounds off then he belted
him because he was there for the taking
in the early rounds
absolutely you can't do that against it
because you can't give rounds up against
yousick and he realized that when he
lost his belts last time absolutely
absolutely because basically for those
who didn't see the fight yusik came in
and stole
the first four rounds i think aj took
rounds five and six and eight and i gave
everything else to u6 so it was nine to
three yeah which is a washout you know
what i mean it wasn't close as much as
the commentators were trying to make it
close one of the main things i noticed
about that fight because i've watched it
back about 10 times now
is uh the trainer oh mccracken cracking
right kraken
there's there's there's there's the chat
in the corner right and i i've never
known anything like this before because
i hung out with [__] pro boxers i
know i know the crack and they're
telling me like you know when you when
you have a kid come into the corner and
sit down
you give them a second of a breath give
them a drink of water you tell him one
or two things you know what i mean not
like a whole boatload of instructions
he's not going to be able to digest a
lot in a minute and the amount of things
rob mccracken is saying
it's like step on your job ah side to
side
you could see the panic within rob
mccracken through the amount of like
he's like he's like telling him how to
like drive a car you know i mean he's
doing everything for him in his head and
you can't do that you can't program aj
you like in the fight it needs to be
similar to what john kavanagh said when
he came on the podcast like all that has
been sort of like drilled in a regular
fighter it's just a little like one two
like i have a one positive one negative
that's it you can't go do this do that
do that because it's gonna overwhelm aj
and when you're dealing with someone
like usic you've got to make sure that
you are completely focused and i think
the thing with aj was you have to give
aj that confidence and that inner belief
within him like you have to help him
with that that's the thing that he in my
opinion lacks the most as a fighter i
look at him i think you have everything
people call him chinny i don't think
he's chinny i think he's in the
heavyweight division you know like it's
a [__] hard hit us how's he chinny
well
people have seen his legs stiffen up
from taking shots from ruiz and
klitschko but realistically well it was
that one instance really oh i guess yeah
with the klitschko potentially but yeah
and dillian white sort of caught them as
well but the point i'm making is you
know you have 20 odd fights in the
heavyweight division you kind of have
moments where you've got to hang on
fury's been dropped multiple times he's
ever been knocked out cold
exactly like deontay wow but it was it
was the it was the the state of mind
that's failed them in the ruiz one fight
and also in i don't know if you remember
on that reverse rubies where he's like
why am i feeling like this yeah yeah i
didn't even know what the shot was
it wasn't good so but he obviously over
underestimated ruiz and he also got
caught with a lucky punch from the gods
yeah so so that was
time
it was a very different circumstance and
he knew that he was better a better
boxer than ruiz and he knew what to do
in the rematch and it was very clear-cut
what he needed to do and that's where
eddie hearn was so confident it's like
get the rematch booked do it in abu
dhabi sorted beaten ruiz gets his belts
back and he was so relieved i don't
think that same level of like right i
know what i need to do is there for you
sick i think there's definitely much
more fear going into this fight and
uncertainty there is so much
there's no clear path to win no there
isn't people go he's a rubik's cube he
just needs to knock him out it's like
okay but even then
aj could do everything right and still
not win that's the difference here is
with ruiz we knew the path that little
fat man was not going to be able to move
his legs around that ring quick enough
against a six-foot six-man gliding it
was 17 stone shredded you know exactly
and this is going to be different
because it's a much harder challenge if
you if you want to look at a fight and
just break it down into the basics of
what advantages you give aj versus usic
there's very little advantages for aj
and yet a lot of people don't speak like
that a lot of people think aj because
he's the bigger man it's oh well he's
bigger man he should win it's like
all right he hits a bit harder but like
to me it's like fight iq footwork like
uh head movement like so many different
parts of the game
or in music's favor and i also think one
of the main things is
aj is normally the better athlete and i
think usyk is a better athlete than aj
overall yeah you know people might think
i'm wrong but i have never seen and i've
got to give credit to aj because that
first fight he kept up with you sick for
a long time he did better than i thought
he would because i know beforehand
obviously the aj was the favorite going
into that fight and i remember me and
you being like i think we think music is
going to win this week yeah i i mean i
got used to by decision i wouldn't
[__] good money oh really sound good
that's it um um yeah but it's it's much
harder to fight for aj
stamina
i've never seen a heavyweight do that
that pace and they were in the one thing
the commentator said which sort of blew
me away was like he does four minute
rounds with half a minute rest on his
training camp so like he is used to
an intense pace and so to try and keep
up with him
i just think was a mistake because aj
what what you notice he starts doing
halfway through the fight he starts like
peppering him but
like that's not what you do as a big man
you want to nail him with a job yeah you
want to throw one job that's very hard
not three where you're like you know
when you're pulling yeah it's not no you
can't you're not gonna do you're not
gonna take enough out of using in order
to win a fight by doing that he needs to
throw
um for leather you need to just go in
there yeah and just try and knock it
less often than what he was but with
much
worse intentions exactly and to the body
especially because when someone's moving
that much you've got to hit what's not
moving as much which is the core the
center yes and that'll perfect that'll
hurt the gas tank and break them down
but because i guess ruiz too he had to
play it safe he cannot play it safe this
time and that's where the risk comes
that's part of the problem is the jig is
up a little bit for for a genius like
usic he knows that there is a point in
this fight where aj can't go in there
and wait for the knockout to happen yeah
he has to force the issue
so it's kind of like years is going and
they're gone at some point you're gonna
come for me and when you do i'm gonna
know i'm gonna know that that's what
you're initiating and i'm going to have
the answers ready and i do think that
the weight gain from music is he's
planning
something and with usic being the
southpaw who throws very unorthodox like
there was a moment where he threw two
left hooks like back to back and like
naturally as a fighter when you block
one you naturally come and expect the
other one and it [__] bang you know
like he does things that are just weird
he's also had 12 rounds already with aj
which is gonna benefit his confidence
massively because he's been in there
with him the the fear level is gone and
he's nearly finished him exactly
without without that being the game plan
yeah so the main thing for me when i
look at this fight is
aj has to pull the trigger at some point
and when he does
if he doesn't get you sick out of there
there is no way
that that he'll make another
four rounds to recover the way he does
with everybody else exactly and that's
where usyk will go okay you've had yours
now i'm gonna get mine in and i just
think the the pace that yusik puts on
any fighter who is of that size
it's weird because he he was able to
take away like a four inch reach
advantage out jab the bigger man that's
crazy um because of that
lateral movement so um yeah
unfortunately i don't see aj winning but
the the weird thing about all of this is
heavyweight boxing though obviously one
shot can change everything look it is
that but it's it's the tyson fury
situation around it this guy is trying
to make a fight with derek chizora i saw
someone say this the other day it's like
khabib coming back and fighting um dan
hooker
yeah
it's it's it's it's just chizzora jizora
sorry i would never say that to the guy
put that with you
he's one of the most intimidating men in
oh my god he looked great in his last
fight against against pool level if
boxing had a bmf belt that is just for
the 100 yeah yeah it's derrick azor he
is the bmf like it doesn't matter if he
wins or loses you're coming out of there
like you've been in a [__] car
accident exactly like he puts it on you
so this isn't disrespectful to zora it's
just acknowledging where he's at in his
career and the fact that tyson fury is
clearly looking for an easy fight and
the fact that he's scrambling around
trying to make this fight and by the way
eddie hearn has received an offer so
there's legitimacy anything to promote
the fight no eddie hearn's the manager
of chizzard of course he's seen the
contract they've sent the contract over
i thought this was all you know tyson
fury i'm only fighting for free i'm only
fighting for half a billion oh i want
derek jazara it's the first heavyweight
trilogy that's happened to uh two two
fights uh two heavyweight trilogy fights
yeah he's actually made an offer so
there's some seriousness around this i
should sort of called out fury or is it
just fury this is attitude
i don't understand why tyson fury
instead of aj are you sick because
obviously they're fighting now so surely
if i was starting fury he'd wait back
could find out who wins
and then make my move why call out
think about think about the only logical
reason that i can think of anyway
no why do you want to organize a fight
before the winner is selected between
the two main rivals why would you want
to be disposed why would you want to be
stuck fighting someone else when that
win has announced why do you not want to
be eligible i can't understand any other
reason i don't know because i don't
think tyson fury is scared of those guys
yeah so there's there's two reasons he's
either he either doesn't want the fight
or he wants a tune-up with uh
to chazora something that long since he
beat white exactly it's just nonsensical
i think he's bored i think he's just
bored you know what i think it is wait a
week if the fight is like two weeks did
you see the video do you see the video
where he announces it he's like i'm
gonna make my comeback i'm fighting zoro
with my new trainer isaac low so you
know isaac low is isaac low is a guy who
uh he's i can't remember if he's like a
strawberry or something uh so he's a
fighter very good fighter he's fought on
many of tyson fury's undercard and he
was undefeated i'm pretty sure until
very recently on the white fury card
where he lost and he got beat quite
badly he actually got stopped and i feel
like what's happened i may be wrong but
this is what i got from the video is
he's lost his fight recently he's
probably a bit down in the dump he's a
very good friend of tyson tyson's put
his arm around him and said listen isaac
i'm gonna make my comeback and you're
gonna be my trainer
so he's done a video people need to
start saying no yeah exactly so he's
done this video where he keeps saying i
don't train her isaac and isaac just sat
there like
i have no idea what the [__] is going on
in tyson fury's mind i don't think
anybody has ever known
ever because tyson fury we knew when he
said he's not going to come back we knew
that he was going to come back as much
as i respect chazora though
if tyson fury versus derek chizora was
happening in my back garden i wouldn't
look through the blinds i have no
interest yes you [__] wonder
i'll be gone what the [__] just
already out there
no um
but seriously it's just the most
pointless fight ever oh yeah he he could
beat director zoro with one arm tie
behind his back exactly it's it's that
bad i don't want to say it so and that's
why i didn't think why don't you don't
insult the fans by even talking about
this about
an easy payday or whatever the [__] is
going on in his mind we have interest in
one fight and one fight only the winner
and i if there's one thing i i do think
is he's unsure of you sick
i think he's very like this whole thing
about you being a middleweight and all
that it's like
alexander youssef is is very much a
heavyweight though yeah and he handled
aj with ease it's a serious serious
threat in that division
music has attributes
ahead of everyone in that division in in
terms of ring iq in terms of uh speed in
terms of stamina he will be he will be
in the ring with fury and have
advantages that no one else has had
exactly exactly
now and obviously that would be the fact
that everyone want to see
i don't want to say fury against anyone
else look at zora if i was fury right
now i would just call it a day but
obviously i know that you say like he
needs to fight you know the like or the
the greatest heavyweights ever for
everybody in their sort of era but fury
in my opinion can just stop now it
depends on the ego i think there was a
time where he would talk about the
greatest of all time and he would say
you know i'm the greatest of my era but
i'm not the greatest ever because you
know i don't want to be competitive but
lately just been like yeah i'm the goat
i'm the greatest ever and it's like may
you're not you can't emphatically say
that say you're the greatest now because
there are fighters out there who you
haven't beaten who are legitimate like
aj like you said i agree yeah i don't i
believe he beats both of them i think
he's proven the biggest point though of
all the heavyweights in this era right
now to to come back from where he came
where he was and and to do what he did
against deontay wilder
twice tell you what though if yousik
beats aj
yusuke has an equal claim in my opinion
because he's a two-way world champion
not just a two-way world champion he's
an undisputed cruiserweight and he's a
unified uh heavyweight champion he has
done a lot in that in with a win against
bellew i claim to what sorry but being
the greatest heavyweight in terms of
just being the greatest boxer of his
generation i i put him okay in that
bracket
equal to tyson fury if not more so
because he's done it at two weights how
hard it is to go from cruiserweight up
the heavyweight it it's so difficult
that only evander holyfield had done it
before him i'd be interested to see uh
yusuke against some other opponents
before that claim uh obviously because
he's had three at that point
fights she's not in the ring with him
and then joshua twice yeah i think we
would need that big tie breaker in a way
tyson the difference between music and
fury is one of them says he doesn't care
about the money and the other one really
doesn't care about the money yeah usyk
is actually about legacy music is a true
fighter he is not a showman he is an
actual just a total you know the spartan
[__] that's actually what you sick is in
my opinion i watched a documentary on
youtube once and he literally is in i
think ukraine where he's from and he's
like away in the woods up in the hills
and he like juggles because he obviously
trains that with lochenko he's very much
like that as well just practicing his
hand-eye coordination and all these
things yeah he's like yeah a fight
through and through yeah he's a genius
and he lives and breathes it there's no
you know meltdowns coming from music or
anything like that no no
this is all he cares about legacy legacy
legacy music would fight fury deontay
wilder all of them if given the
opportunity there's no games there's no
pull outs there's no [__] around
yusik when he says something he means
and for me the longer this goes on the
more i like you sick of course
i rate his his attributes his stamina
all of that but his personality but his
personality he's so
trustworthy yeah you know what's going
to turn up there ain't no andy ruiz two
stone since he won the belts turning up
he is going to show up if not better
yeah i just have to respect that you
know as much as i like fury and i am
he's a countryman and i want him to do
well there's a little bit of me that
when we watch aj you take i will kind of
not abort
i won't i won't want aj to lose but if
yousick wins and i believe he will win
i'm gonna be happy for him because he is
such a [__]
like gangster about this [__] you know
what i mean
i just know for a fact that if there's
any issues
with tyson fury getting in the ring with
you sick and you know how they try to
smoke and mirrors yeah it'll be [__]
frank warren pointing the finger and all
it won't be yusik who pulls out no there
is no way that yusik pulls out against
any he's he is he is as good as his word
there's no doubt
i don't wanna yeah
yeah gamebread you sick me interestingly
i don't know if you saw this but when
tyson fury made the announcement video
saying he was fighting chizzora and as
low as his trainer his old trainer or i
say old recently uh sugar hill sugar
hill steward he responded and it would
like basically i can't remember exactly
what he said but it was very much along
the lines of [__] hell love to see
how this goes
it's it's literally like two dads at a
barbecue man that's the level that this
is at that like it does not deserve
people complaining about ksi versus
swarms
way less than that you know what i mean
like i don't want to say it we've seen
it twice it cleared it up what what part
of the boxing community are like hmm i
really that'll really settle it once and
for all it is it's literally like khabib
coming back and fighting dan hooker
don't sell us a pile of [__] exactly and
try and expect us to buy it you know so
i think that the
tyson's had so much love from the boxing
community in the last few years
but they're all yeah and right he's
earned it with blood sweat and tears but
they're all groans starting they're all
like what the [__] like and i'm feeling
it myself this whole 500 billion a
million thing i mean you might as well
say a billion at this rate it's [__]
and and then i want to fight on free tv
i want to fight chazora
he loves the limelight doesn't it no but
this is the thing though is like he
doesn't need to box for that reality tv
show or something like that i like fury
and he's doing one with on netflix right
so this is a reality tv show i don't
give a [__] about money i'm a spartan oh
my god and it's like but this is the pro
this is the problem with fury you can't
take his word for anything and that's
what i like about you he's a man of his
word whereas with fury
everything he says you have to go
it could mean anything this exactly like
and but when you say you're a fighter
you're a spartan and there is no doubt
he is that but he is not just that and
when he says i don't care about the
money it's like why do you go on tour
and do every [__] arena in the
[__] country why have you got three
autobiographies when you've got one life
what you know
this is the thing like why are you
trying to set fights up against fighters
who you could beat so easily
it it's a cash grab all of it is a cash
grab of course so when he says he
doesn't care about money it's the
biggest pile of [__] i've ever heard in
my life i love tyson fury but the guy
and we know this haven't been on the
podcast he is full of contradictions i
mean part of that's intriguing and
exciting and but don't just don't expect
us to
there's got to come a point where as as
fight fans
you are relying on us buying into you
and when you keep moving the gold post
and keep lying and doubling back on
yourself and doing all the
it makes it harder to be a fan because i
don't know what i'm what i'm getting
anymore whereas with you sick
i feel i very feel i i very fail i know
i feel like of course the the the
baddest [__] on the planet in my
opinion i believe yousick
can beat tyson fury i believe he can't
title yeah so
just saying i think you take tyson fury
way too seriously i'll just take him
with a pinch of salt no but but this is
the point though is it's it's getting
heated about him though it's it's
it's more that um
i'm calling you out
history he might [__] take that fight
um
i'm definitely not calling you up but
but the point i'm making is i just feel
like i'm saying what a lot of his fans
are feeling right now which is when he
left the limelight and came back he came
back
so sincere so real so humble it's like a
massive reality check and it was like
i'm sorry you know i want to repair the
build the bridges with the fans and it
just feels like he's going a bit off the
race yeah and and the people who
i look to to keep him in line
like sugar hill are now like the [__]
he doing you know what i mean i don't
know
isaac loses his mate
it's it's literally like me and you just
rocking up and doing a youtube fight
come and you coaching me exactly
it's just [__] mental so all i'm
saying is i just hope you can have all
the fun you want yeah but when the
winner of this is announced
whoever's got their hand raised i'm
looking squarely at tyson fury and going
you ready mate because i don't want to
hear anything any excuses i agree if you
want to call yourself the goat there's
only one way to prove it and whoever
gets in the ring after that if if for
any reason
i'm just saying this now for any reason
tyson fury does not step in the ring
with the winner of aj versus usic
then that guy becomes the goal of this
generation because whoever's willing to
fight you have automatically won because
you're the one willing okay i don't want
to hear any excuses i don't give a [__]
there we go no more i agree talking to
us i don't want to hear your stories i
want to see your fight man you know what
i mean i'd love to see this reality tv
show though you see it's on netflix yeah
the last one the last one the last one
was really good i don't know if you saw
that i'm not looking living with the
fury fury such a great person paris is
like
she is a character in our own right like
she she is one of my favorite people in
boxing oh my god and you can see how
he's done so well with the proper woman
behind him like her so shout out to
paris but like i say
you could do that later bro get in the
ring find out who the best is and then
dine out on all your success for the
rest of your [__] life yeah should we
talk about some mma yeah ufc what what's
happening in the world of mma right now
so uh what's his name kamaru uzman is
defending his uh welterweight belt
against
uh our countryman leon edwards that
fight's been in the in the works for a
long time now obviously leon edwards uh
coming off a uh a decent win against
nate diaz well basically he just
schooled him for five rounds but he did
get caught in that last round but
leonardo has been wanting a tattle shot
for a long time looks not been you know
in his in his favor um kamara uzman he's
on a great streak at the moment one
difference is he's just had a big
operation on his hand which took a while
to recover from so there is a little bit
of
a worry there is because that right hand
was was his money maker for for a good
while there only recently obviously
oozman uh fundamentally is a wrestler um
but he's fallen in love with his hands
um a lot recently because he's knocking
people out like he knocked out burns he
dropped colby multiple times and he's
absolutely not flattered out
and nate diaz can rock um leonardo
dicaprio sorry there's no reason why
oozman can't kill leon edwards so leon's
gonna have to be
quick on his game i know he's a great
striker he is really high level he's the
most technical striker the uzman's
fought in a long time because burns is a
wrestler colby is a wrestler myself a
striker but he's not a technical striker
he's more of a volume striker and also
like mazda never belonged in that top
level leon's a sharp shooter yeah i
think mars this street style is is is
effective but leon is another level
leon is the biggest challenge for usman
in that division with the obviously the
asterisks of hamza which obviously that
would be a very exciting fight if it
does happen but edwards is going to
present um a very different challenge do
you give him much of a chance yeah i
think he actually has a decent chance i
think uzman obviously is
pound number one at the moment he is a
very very good fighter he's only got one
loss to usman ironically leon hasn't he
i think he may have two losses on his
record i'm not 100 sure obviously yeah
this is a rematch they've fought before
uh oozman won the first fight it was a
decision win um but since then uzman has
just got better and better it's scary
with usman because every time he gets in
there he looks better and better
the hand is going to be an issue but
it's very interesting to see what
approach um he takes against edwards
because i don't think he's going to
stand in strike with him unless he has
fallen in love with his hands a bit and
he decides this is the approach i want
to take you know what though when you're
watching nate diaz rock him though there
must be a bit of usement thinking if if
let's be real nate diaz is not a power
puncher
oozman is
and if he can rock you oozman can kill
you exactly yeah and they're gonna fit
around as well it's not just like a
overhand right like yeah he's got that
but his his jab his jab was so good he
dropped burns with the jab as well and
with uh i think he also dropped uh colby
with a job yeah he did um he looks
really good and it's i don't think he
he's a better striker than leon though
leon is just so quick his footwork is
really good he's almost got that sort of
like nami younes style sort of moving
around i agree but i also didn't think
he was a better striker than mas vidal i
i just think that he lined up masvidal
to where he delivered the punch after
taking a few after allowing because
right before that final punch comes
masvid i was like smiling laughing
playing the game he let masward all get
a bit comfortable he did but also
maslodel didn't expect him to stand in
strike with it yeah he thought he was
going to wrestle him because obviously
they had the first fight at uc 251 where
there was much more wrestling it was
[__] pushed against the cage it
wasn't great uzman wanted to make a
statement and prove to maseradar that he
didn't deserve to be at the top level of
the welterweight division and he did
that knocked him out cold no one
expected that to happen but going into
this fight obviously he's dealing with
the weakness of with us
it's the mental game i i look at usman
as one of the most mentally strong
fighters i've ever seen i think if it
goes the distance though is the it's the
approach either fighter need to take
because i don't see anyone finishing the
other in this fight the thing about leon
that sort of frustrated me against nate
was he did not do what i wanted him to
do which is risk it a little more and
put the the the
win round yeah i wanted him to put the
gas on and get nate diaz the [__] out of
there and prove that the level he's on
and when he let him live and he let him
stay in there with him and didn't risk
it he got caught and i just look at that
and i think that that is a flaw within
you not in the technique not in the
athleticism but within him yeah where it
takes balls to put the afterburners on
and try and kill someone because it's
kill you're giving you're giving the
opportunity to them as well in the same
breath yeah and
usman has
a sight to him
that makes him a champion mentally and i
haven't seen that from leon yet i
haven't seen
i've seen a very accurate clever
technical striker but i have not seen
the killer and to me
with the level of ferocity that colby
covington brought at the table twice
that didn't get rid of him with with
what usman has seen in gilbert burns
we've seen gilbert burns gave um cosmos
hell on earth and yet and and yeah he
knew uzman better than he knew comes out
and yet usman took him apart he you know
they train together for years i'm just
the way i look at usman he is
champions tested here like he has passed
every test no matter how hard no matter
how injured whatever he was going
through
it's up here where he has that elite
mentality so i just don't feel like
leon's shown that no i agree to make me
believe he can win no definitely i agree
and obviously as you were saying he
played it safe against nate diaz who was
on the tail end of his career literally
retiring after his next fight yeah he
gets beaten about hamza obviously and
now he's going in there against the
pound-for-pound champion but obviously
the guys have fought before i don't
think that oozman is going to be
overlooking edwards in any way um but
also as well you know when you're
fighting the champion you have to rip
the belt off them and it you know when
you've got the power of power number one
someone that makes a ufc a lot of money
um edwards is gonna have to do a lot and
really like win each round um did you
see the move volkmanovsky is number one
poem for pogba did they i think so yeah
off of uzman you know what's funny i
didn't know they did that but i um i
agree with that it's a tricky one though
i've i feel like in order for pound for
pound number one to lose that title like
canelo did he lost the fight
for me
if you look at the battles usman's had
and the names he's beaten
and it's not that i don't really give me
the names i think colby covington is as
well-rounded a fighter as in the ufc
definitely that's a star um top level i
think gilbert burns is very high level
the way he dragged hams out into deep
waters i think recently he's really
proven himself yeah yeah um uh
i think mas vidal vidal's up there but i
would not stop but i wouldn't i wouldn't
have him as the top top tier even though
he had that he had the sauce the thing
is with mas vidal he when he landed that
flying knee that put his name into an
echelon where it did not belong and then
obviously he had the big fight with nate
diaz and things like that but then we
were all blinded to the fact that this
guy wasn't just a journeyman but he was
now a title contender he never belonged
in that top top echelon so therefore i
don't i wouldn't have a big
some of his other wins tyron woodley
which yeah i think in retrospect like
milk yeah jake paul's definitely not
helped the uh so when he got the win
when he got the win yes definitely but
then ever since then not just jake paul
when he got beat by luke covington and
burns he's beaten there sean strickland
he's beaten damien maya raphael dossanos
it it's it's on leon himself before so i
think the point is is
well away and all comers have been seen
too okay whereas we're going years about
by the way with some of those other wins
yeah i i look at what and obviously they
weren't like emphatic wins like he was
basically getting decisions all the time
and things like that max holloway for me
while i rate him highly i don't have him
on the level of colby at all really nah
i think he's just like as a striker he's
just so good yeah no he is he is a very
good fighter i just think that the
dimensions and the intensity and the
will to win that colby brings
is i i view colby as just an unofficial
champion if usman wasn't here colby's
that that man okay i agree i look at max
and i whereas i see i see more
vulnerabilities than max's game than
what i see in colby but yeah that's
that's by the by i just felt like
regardless it's it's not trying to take
away anything from volkmanovsky he's a
quality fighter and he's definitely
pound for pound is [__] anyway to me
but to just take that title off oozman
when he hasn't lost was ridiculous so
one way i would justify um having
volkanovskiy is number one is as you say
if usman didn't exist copy would be the
champion now if you look at the uh
featherweight division if volkowski
didn't exist it'd probably be max
holloway so if you get those two
fighters four fighters if you look at
the distance between um oozman and colby
in terms of level they're actually like
almost like the same
yeah no i i guess volkowski has just
proven against max holloway obviously he
had a few close fights but he has just
proven why he deserves to be pound pound
against holloway in the last five what
do you mean because there's such a gap
bro he just absolutely annihilated him
for every single round okay so on the
flip side i i just think that the
welterweight division is more stacked
than featherweight and one of the
reasons for that is the average man the
average sized giza walking down the
street
is in that welt away middleweight height
range so i feel like you're going to
just naturally get a more in-depth
talent pool
uh gravitating
and i think that uh it's the most stack
division in the ufc and i look i think
colby comes out like there's just such
great names in that division but yeah i
agree that with volkanovsky in my
opinion just recently obviously the way
that he comfortably dealt with korean
zombie and then coming back only a few
months later to beat max holloway
someone that's given him his hardest
fights in his career and to be able to
um beat him in the way that he did just
comfortably beat him over five rounds
let's not forget last year as well the
amazing fight with brian ortega where it
looked multiple times like he was going
to be stopped and he managed to leave
him in a pool of his own blood like in
after that third round after he was
almost finished ortega was had to be
helped to the to the stool by his corner
one thing you can say about that fight
ortega did give him some big problems he
did and maybe bigger problems than what
usman's been in at times but only
multiple times but here's the thing
though sorry i didn't here's the thing
with volkonovsky though
volkanovsky battered ortega question for
you about wakanovsky can he win the belt
at lightweight because to me if he does
that
then the argument is a very strong
argument
obviously um so there's a lightweight
fight title fight that's scheduled
between islam
and uh charles oliveira um i never
really rated charles oliveira that
highly obviously because the guy he lost
to donald cerrone i mean if you look
he's he's beatable yeah exactly and i
thought that when he him versus michael
chandler happened i thought chandler was
going to beat him obviously he knocks
out chandler no one expects him to do
that and then he goes and fights poirier
and then we're thinking poirier's proven
he's a great fighter he's just knocked
out mcgregor twice basically
he beats poirier easily second round
third round and then he goes against
gateshead and that was the real test it
was like right gait she's a tough
customer against chandler he looks so
good
and against ferguson when he just
annihilates ferguson we had this idea
that gaichi was like a top top level guy
he submits him in less than 30 seconds
or whatever it was so he made it got it
was so good he made khabib's win against
gaichi looked less impressive and now
we've gone from sort of like overlooking
charles oliveira to going is he better
than khabib so can volkanovsky win the
belt at lightweight
you know what it is very tough the size
of charles as well he's he's a big
lightweight and actually volkmanovsky
isn't even a big featherweight
so that's and also you know ortega let's
give him credit like he tc like he is a
great uh submission specialist but i
don't think he's on the jiu-jitsu level
of charles oliveira and olivet this is
the oliveira era the oliveira era we're
in right now and i think it would be
very hard for volkonovsky to win that
belt and i think there's good fights for
him in in the lightweight division if he
decides to move up but jumping straight
for a title shot i think uh it's going
to be tough but then against makachev
i'd give him a better chance
because i also think that makka chip is
going to beat oliveira
macaceb is by the way huge for a
lightweight he's seen a fight with him
next to usman he's much bigger than his
man yeah he's a big guy he's crazy the
lightweight division is so exciting man
michael chandler apparently is going to
be fighting dustin poirier that's going
to be such an exciting thing that's so
fun you know what's funny take mcgregor
at the equation we've just got so many
amazing fights in there we don't even
need mcgregor right now mcgregor's
mcgregor's on his [__] boat having
some sunshine exactly and and that's
where you should stay yeah you know 100
because the ufc is on fire right now
this is all the exciting fights being
made he's got no business in there with
these guys anymore no truthfully no you
can't be signing up on the yacht for
[__] months on end of the year yeah
for the last [__] knows how long and
then jump back in with these savages
especially in the divisions that he
wants to go into that lightweight and
welterweight and he's [__]
it's gonna be very tough for him i think
the chandler fight would have been good
because i think chandler is a winnable
fight for him i think yeah style-wise i
i hear what you see i think
2016 conor mcgregor finishes today's
michael chandler in less than two rounds
it's a chad mendes style matchup exactly
very similar
he's made for that and that may be one
of the few fights that is winnable but
generally speaking gaitry pourier
would be a very tough fight even even
worse obviously mata i think charles
actually stylistically is more of a
competitive matchup but still i would
not fancy it i think charles knows
exactly what he would need to do and he
would do it very quickly like he did
against gaitry he didn't want to stand
in the pocket with guilty and trade with
him he was like the first opportunity i
get to take him down or drop him
whatever i'm taking his back and i'm
taking him out of there i'm proving i'm
the champion and exactly exactly i've
enjoyed this chat it's been great um big
shout out to you uh yeah i think we've
flown back we've covered a lot here big
love to uh duo uh we'll get him back on
on the playing game you know we need to
do we need to do more knockouts bro we
need to get because people love doing
the knockout streams yeah we need more
sponsorships yeah any brand that's
watching this [__] any betting
company whatever we need sponsors for
the knockout because we need to watch
the ufc event every week because there's
someone missing bro amanda nunes versus
juliana pena just happened i think yeah
the only reason as well is because the
ufc is on so [__] late to playing in
the office
but i'm up let's watch him yeah you're
right you're right we need to do more uh
big love to geo don't forget follow the
boy on all his socials i'll put that in
the the description and um yeah thanks
mate appreciate your worries i've
enjoyed it don't forget the like button
subscribe thanks for watching and we'll
see you later